il est officiellement le premier
libanais à se faire vacciner contre le
coc vie 19
lui c'est le docteur marco d'hassoun
chef du service de soins intensifs de
l'hôpital rafic hariri au sud de
beyrouth
et dès ce dimanche le liban lance sa
campagne de vaccination sont concernés
l'ensemble du personnel médical et les
citoyens de plus de 75 ans pour le
précédent premier ministre est la
vaccination représente une première
étape vers le retour à la vie normale
nous lançons la campagne nationale de
vaccination contre le coc vide 19 avec
des vaccins de haute qualité efficace et
digne de confiance
[Musique]
par la suite nous commencerons à lever
petit à petit les restrictions que cette
pandémie nous a imposé et donc la vie
reprendra dans des secteurs variés
quand nous aurons atteint l'immunité
collective souhaiter une bonne nouvelle
également pour les hôpitaux du pays
nombre d'entre eux sont saturés le taux
d'occupation soins intensifs est souvent
très élevé
une campagne est vécue comme un
véritable soulagement par le personnel
soignant libanais aujourd'hui nous
venons nous faire vacciner
nous sommes vraiment heureux parce que
honnêtement c'est fatigant au travail on
a tout le temps peur chaque patient dont
vous vous approchez pour faire un bilan
de santé
vous ne savez pas s'il est positive au
co vide ou non nous devons toujours
prendre toutes les précautions
donc nous sommes très heureux
depuis le début de l'épidémie
334 milles libanais ont été touchés par
le colis de 19 avec près de 4000 morts
avec cette campagne de vaccination le
pays espère désengorger les hôpitaux et
continuer la levée progressive des
restrictions imposées le 8 février
dernier